kleines köpfchen und ab zur arbeit über
500 meter sind zum bundestag zum laufen
leider zu weit ich checke den bundestag
auf energieverbrauch und muss
feststellen es gibt sparpotenzial zum
thema energiesparen braucht man jetzt
wirklich die komplette union oder kann
man nicht die csu
zeitweise stilllegen ich meinen
öffentlich-rechtlich treten auch
zusammenlegen das meinte er das hätte
energie gespart hätten ganz schön frech
was muss man überhaupt jeden tag duschen
weil es heißt ja auch so schön man
riecht nur mit dem herzen gut
also es gibt einige kollegen wo ich
sagen würde
man sollte nicht weiter sparen an einmal
waschen gehören nicht zu den anderen
waschlappen empfehlen hauptsache wir
diskutieren nicht wieder wer zuhause
waschlappen benutzt das schlägt mir dann
wieder aufs gemüt aber es gibt dinge die
möchte ich aus dem intimbereich gar
nicht wissen
benutzen sie einen waschlappen mich
würde interessieren aber nur aus also
energiespar politischen gründen ja ich
habe welche ja aber wir wollten ja nicht
darüber reden was hab ich vergessen ja
ja ja richtig richtig wie dankbar sind
sie eigentlich armin laschet dass sie in
diesen tagen nicht regieren müssen
ja
so ist das die wählerinnen und wähler
haben entschieden und jetzt haben wir
eine wichtige aufgabe in der opposition
das ist ja auch immer leicht da kann man
jetzt schon sagen er macht alles fertig
zwei kammern danke danke danke der armut
zu werten wir hätten das gerne gemacht
und ein mit laschet l werden guter
bundeskanzler geworden besser als olaf
scholz ja
auch nicht hier wird doch noch so
einiges verbraucht hätte man besser mal
nord stream 2 auf gemacht wobei auch
kubicki rauchen die idee hatte dass man
die ja wieder aufmachen kann das wie
finden sie die idee da merkst du einfach
dass manche leute nicht rechnen können
nämlich durch vier pipelines durch die
kein gas läuft bleibt trotzdem bei null
grad also oben märz 20 30 oder 40 kommt
immer noch null raus ich finde wir
sollten konsequenzen alle pipelines
schließen dass wir doch mal ein mutiger
schritt also ich habe nicht gesagt
gewissen den zwei aufmachen sondern wenn
putin sagt er liefert über 19 2 soll
immer gucken ob das stimmt oder nicht
stimmt aber die sagen mir ist das
relativ latte ich heize nicht mit gras
ich habe kein gas insofern soll die liga
sah man schließlich frage stellen wo
roboter der sehr gut was glauben sie wie
viel strom könnte man sparen wenn man
karl lauterbach die twitter app vom
telefon nimmt
wahrscheinlich eine kleinstadt mit
versorgung es ist tatsächlich also da
geht viel energie verloren es hat fast
schon block stehen endlich also
dimensionen dann wird mir ginge
lebensenergie verloren aber also was den
strom angeht würde man viel einsparen es
geht um die energiesparverordnung und
was sie davon schon persönlich umgesetzt
haben das würde mich jetzt mal
interessieren ich komme meistens mit
nassen haaren
wer ist das wirklich so ja es ist
wirklich so ich finde das vorbildlich er
hofreiter dass sie sagen sie sparen
energie indem sie mit nassen haaren in
den bundestag kommen und deswegen
kriegen sie von uns jetzt einen preis
sie kriegen von uns ist es
natürlich
irgendwie kriegen den goldenen robert
von uns
zeigen sie in voller stolz
olaf scholz hat gesagt wir müssen jetzt
mutig in den winter gehen
das war glaube ich immer sich unterhaken
er ist wirklich ein schönes
abschlussbild für diesen beitrag können
wir uns kurz unterhalten und mutig in
den wege ihren mit der schweren tasche
kriegen wir das hin
das sind dabei nicht so viel reden dass
sie nur das schlussbild für den beitrag
ein in die richtung gehen sie denn hin
müssen
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da